wie neidisch haben sie heute auf die
insel gelockt wo die 90-jährige maggie
als erste europäerin mit einem deutschen
impfstoff geimpft worden ist
ich habe mit stolz auf die insel
geschaut ein deutscher impfstoff sie
haben schon gesagt der erste test für
saas 52 wurde in deutschland entwickelt
im januar der erste impfstoff der film
wird kommt aus deutschland
das macht mich stolz auf dieses land und
gleichzeitig freue ich mich für die
briten dass sie schon impfen können wir
sind eben zulassungsprozess auch für
europa für die europäische union
und ich habe übrigens gerade beide
stimmen die einen sagen wir wollen aber
auch gerne jetzt sofort beginnen können
mit dem impfen andere sagen ist
vielleicht ganz gut wenn wir den ersten
zwei drei wochen jetzt auch in
großbritannien schauen können wie es im
real betrieb läuft wichtig ist für mich
dass wir rund um den jahreswechsel auch
in europa anfang die briten als
sogenannte im kaninchen für uns wann ist
denn daran wird in deutschland die erste
im finale gesetzt und wer bekommt sie
denn wer bekommt die erste impfung in
deutschland stand heute das ist ja ein
prozess wo es jetzt natürlich in der
zulassung auch nachfragen geben wird der
behörden an den hersteller aber stand
heute dürfen wir mit einer zulassung zum
ende des jahres rechnen dass beyond
advisor impfstoffes und dann werden wir
rund um den jahreswechsel
spätestens anfang januar beginnen können
mit dem impfen vor allem auch wie es ja
auch die ständige impfkommission
empfiehlt dann in den
pflegeeinrichtungen bei den älteren
genau wie in großbritannien
wann werden denn die ersten drei großen
risikogruppen also die alten die kranken
die pflege der kranken und der alten
oder j auf den profit stationen wann
werden die ersten drei großen gruppen
die priorisiert und dann durch geimpft
sein
wir machen ja zuerst einmal ein
impfangebot dass ja niemand verpflichtet
ist anzunehmen aber das impfangebot an
die besonders priorisierten wie sie
gesagt haben insbesondere auch an die
älteren die besonders älteren über 80
jährigen die die in den
pflegeeinrichtungen wohnen das wollen
wir in den ersten 12 monaten daneben
auch möglich machen vor allem in den
pflegeheimen in dem pflegeheim in
deutschland leben 800.000 gut 800.000
menschen und dort werden eben auch
mobile teams haben es die länder geplant
die kommunen vor ort geplant in die
pflegeeinrichtung kommen und dort eben
das impfen als angebot beginnen wann
werden wir dann so weit sein dass die
hausärzte auf
der normalbürger die müssen können also
die nicht vorbelastet sind die nicht alt
sind die nicht in bestimmten
berufsgruppen arbeiten weil es otto
normal bürger dran stand heute achter
zwölfter mit dem wissen und dem was wir
heute sehen können wir damit rechnen
dass es spätestens ab dem dritten
quartal ausreichend impfstoff geben wird
um dann auch in die breite gehen zu
können jeden der will ein impf angebot
machen zu können
auch mit einem impfstoff der dann in den
hausarztpraxen verimpft werden kann es
geht ja darum minus 70 grad gerade bei
biontech das ginge gar nicht in jeder
haushalts praxis es geht ja auch darum
dass eine beschaffenheit da ist die
logistik in die arztpraxis hinein
möglich macht was mich dabei übrigens
optimistisch macht dass das dann auch
schnell gehen kann wenn wir mal so weit
sind die hausärzte die ärzte kämpfen
gerade über 20 millionen grippe
impfdosen das klappt innerhalb von
wenigen wochen wenn wir einmal da sind
dann denke ich kann es auch schnell
gehen
wann ist denn die bundeskanzlerin dran
und wann ist denn so jemand wirklich
daran überhaupt nicht vorbelastet ist
jung also jung genug ist ein junges aber
jung genug ist und überhaupt nicht
vorbelastet ist weil es die
bundeskanzlerin dran und war später
titel drin
die frau bundeskanzlerin wird sicherlich
irgendwann dann in der altersgruppe 60
zwischen 60 und 70 offenkundig dran sein
das kann ich ihnen jetzt auf eine woche
genau nicht sagen weil alter ist
sozusagen besonders dann über 70 über
80-jährige mit das größte risiko mit
diesem virus das ist ja das auch was so
brutal weh tut etwa in der
pflegeeinrichtung mit zu vielen
todesfällen zu oft und wenn wir die den
über 70-jährigen das impfangebot haben
machen können und denen die in der
pflege arbeiten dann zug um zug geht es
daneben auch die altersklassen runter
sozusagen bis sie dran sind wie weit
sind sie denn so mit dafür zwischen 50
dank 50 ok wird sicherlich dann richtung
jahresmitte gehen und wie er aber
wichtig ist mir ein zimmer mit stand
heute skandal bei der
impfstoffentwicklung halt immer sein
dass ein oder zwei der kandidaten nicht
zur zulassung kommen also mit denen mit
denen wir heute rechnen dürfen begründet
kann das gelingt das ist sondern das
astra chemiker wo man die
die zulassung für anfang nächsten jahres
also für das erste quartal dann halt
erwartet wo man die großbestellung hat
ja wir haben ja wir haben astra zenica
johnson johnson für weg noch mal deutsch
piontek moderner die wahrscheinlich als
zweites zugelassen werden
wir haben von anfang an auch viele
pferde gesetzt so zu sagen weil sie
gerade bei der impfstoffentwicklung
nicht wissen welche pferde wenn mich das
bild behalte tatsächlich ins ziel kommen
impfstoff entwicklung ist sehr komplex
und damit wir sicher auch impfstoff
haben haben wir eben auf viele
verschiedene hersteller und
forscherteams gesetzt eine ganz einfache
frage wie erfährt man dass man daran
dass mit der impfung jetzt zuerst einmal
in den pflegeeinrichtungen wird feuer
eben angekündigt dass das impf team das
mobile team kommt es braucht auch eine
einwilligungserklärung gerade in den
pflegeeinrichtungen werden teilweise
auch dann die betreuerinnen und betreuer
feuer einwilligen müssen also sozusagen
erfolgt die information dann
pflegeeinrichtung für
pflegeeinrichtungen und dann es in den
bundesländern unterschiedlich einige
werden schriftliche einladungen machen
andere machen das angebot sich über eine
telefonhotline einen termin geben zu
lassen ich bin sehr sicher wenn sie dran
sind werden sie es auch sehr schnell mit
kriegen